ah the camcorder doesn't work oh heck
I've tried everything to get the
camcorder to work including putting on
my Paisley shirt and now I'm stuck
making a video on the stupid iSight
camera which can't follow me when I do
this which I do frequently but Hank I'm
gonna persevere not so much because I
want a persevere but because I fear
further punishment and I will take off
my Paisley shirt because it is not your
fault that my camcorder doesn't work and
you should not have to be punished by
looking at my Paisley shirt okay so
today I want to talk about beautiful
luscious eyelashes and malaria so I
gotta know if you're familiar with the
newest trends in eyelash growth but
there's this new drug on the market
called Latisse that grows your eyelashes
and there are also many other eyelash
products on the market I mean there are
tons of treatments for the public health
problem of unbeautiful unluckiest
eyelashes in fact Hank I would argue
that the 2000s have been the greatest
decade in the history of luscious
eyelashes research the mm however have
not been so good at researching drugs
for malaria as long as drug companies
are driven solely by the forces of the
free market there's always going to be
too much money put into eyelash research
and not enough money put into malaria
research now Hank you might be saying
that's the way the world works the world
finds a demand and it fills that demand
with a supply and apparently there is a
massive supply of unluckiest eyelashes
in this world but in fact real free
market economics tells us that we need
to devote much more money to malaria
research because malaria as a public
health problem is a bigger drain on the
world economy than Wall Street bankers
or the foreclosure crisis or Tiger
Woods's infidelity which could actually
single-handedly put golf into a
recession but that's another story
malaria results in billions of lost work
hours because it's a disease that
requires long term care and often
results in long term disability so Hank
here's the thing curing malaria would
not profit the drug company who finds
that cure as quickly or as directly as
curing unleashes eyelashes but that drug
company's profits would go up in the
long run because the worldwide economy
would grow so much so fast
unfortunately the free market itself
isn't forward-thinking enough to figure
that out but Bill Gates is smart enough
to know that even after Kutcher smart
enough to know that he gave $100,000 to
malaria this year well not not to
malaria against malaria
so Inc that's why this year in the
project for awesome I'm going to make a
video in support of malaria research not
I'm altruistic or anything but because I
recognize that if we can cure malaria
I'll be rich and in the meantime as long
as corporations are flushed with eyelash
money we should take it from them so
Hank there's an eyelash improvement
company that's currently having $100,000
giveaway and noted nerdfighter and
YouTube sensation Mika kitty is in that
contest
if she wins most of money is gonna go to
paper college but some of the money is
going to heifer org where she is gonna
buy an ark hey you know how every year
for Christmas I give you a goat from
heifer org but you don't actually get
the good because it goes to someone who
needs it well an ark is where you buy
like a ton of animals for people who
need them so Hank nerdfighteria can help
take some of that eyelash money and put
it into an ark all you got to do is go
to tinyurl.com slash win kitty when
Kitty should be a thing that should be a
word but what should it mean when kitty
what does that mean nerdfighters right
so you go to tinyurl.com slash win kitty
and then you comment on the video and
you rate it that's it that counts as two
votes and you can do that every day
between now and December 21st and then
we can get us an ark in other news
nerdfighters I hope you're getting your
comment and rating fingers ready for the
project for awesome you can now download
a thumbnail to help you make a project
for awesome video at the Ning lastly on
Tuesday we'll be doing a question
Tuesday half of the questions will be
devoted to the project for awesome half
of the questions will be devoted to
relationship advice so leave your
questions about the project for awesome
and nerdfighter like slash internal
dating in the comments I know I pointed
out my pants but I don't want you to
leave them in my pants I want you to
leave them in comments Alibi have a new
camcorder then best wishes
I'm too fast for you I say camera